Do not forget to check out cindi.com
brothers and sisters. One of my most
amazing clothing brands that I wear,
alhamdulillah, owned by Muslims. With
the recent boycott that's going on with
many brands, clothing lines supporting
Israel. Brothers and sisters, you guys
know I've been supporting cindi.com.
I've been wearing their stuff long, long
time ago. Alhamdulillah. And I love
their clothing, brothers and sisters.
It's exactly what I like, alhamdulillah,
when it comes to fitness training,
jogging, just general wear. When I'm
praying, I don't need to worry about my
back showing. Buy it for your family
members, your your uncles, your
brothers, your husbands, whoever it is.
Inshallah, brother and sisters. Buy it
for yourself. Inshallah. It's modal
to brothers and sisters and dear
friends. This is a video being recorded
at Salah Pro Studios. Yes, moved into
our Salah Pro Studios. Alhamdulillah.
And this is where all the magic's going
to happen with the salam etc. We've got
amazing content coming in brothers and
sisters for you guys inshallah to ben at
the salam studios here. But let's get
straight into it inshallah. So guys,
inshallah um this is a video where I
have to applaud this young lady.
Absolutely phenomenal. The way she broke
it down headstrong with a spine against
these two spineless individuals who have
sold out theirel to zionist money and
agenda. And one of them as you know um I
don't know if it was Malcolm X who said
this, I'm not sure. Uh used the term
which I don't like using a house negro.
Yes. and he would talk about the one
who's basically a sellout. And this
woman herself or anyone for this matter,
it's not something that is said to black
people. It can be a white person, an
Asian, uh, you know, uh, do you get what
I'm trying to say in that context, in so
here's the videos, in let's watch it how
they tried to corner her, but oh my
gosh, she destroys them. Let's watch it
for oursel.
>> I I just noticed that you've not
condemned Hamas.
>> Oh, so sorry. I've noticed you not
condemned Hamas. You know, it's like
going and say, "Hey, I've noticed you
didn't put enough salt salt in my food."
Hey, did you fill up my tire enough? Is
there water in the winter? It's like
It's like something like the essential
thing you need to do, the essential
guide to your daily life. I've just
noticed you have not condemned Hamas.
What a makes me sick. This woman makes
me sick.
>> Where was the condemnation for Hamas?
Are you saying that what happened on
October the 7th was
>> actually asking her husband, "Where was
my flowers today? I've realized you did
not bring flowers today home." Yes. She
sounds very posh as well, you know,
trying to fit in. You know, she's trying
to fit in nicely. You'll never fit in,
darling. After they get rid of Muslims,
they're coming for you in love.
>> When you when you do this, another
another
in the media do this. Again, it is
justified. Nothing justifies genocide
against
>> Can you answer the question? Cuz I'm
trying to pee to the white man sitting
right next to me. So, please answer the
question so they can know that I'm on
their side and validation. You insecure
and spineless intellectual of a
woman you are. Do not forget what they
did to your ancestors. Do not forget the
transatlantic slave trade. Okay? Um if
you were sitting here in the 40s or 50s
or even the 60s or 70s, subhan Allah,
you'll be sitting at the back of the bus
and other racism that you would have to
suffer. But you're here so casually now
innocent children are being massacred
and you are there trying to appease that
flipping white man next to you.
>> Palestinian people. I'm here to tell you
I'm here to tell you exactly what I
think. Exactly what I think. Could you
just I'm not I'm not going to and
condemn Hamas. I'm not going to do that.
I'm going to stand here and condemn the
IDF, the occupation, and the role of
Western imperialism in that entire I
want you guys to download the Salah Pro
app. Our app is out. We're a charity.
Alhamdulillah. This app has a ad free
kiblinder. It has salah reminders,
encourages to pray, book a salah
instructor, book a Quran instructor. You
can order a guided prayer map for
absolutely free around the world. There
is a tutorial guide on how to pray
salah. You can find your local Salah
hub. The app is for absolutely free on
Android and iOS. Salah Pro. Order it now
in brother sisters and use it and let it
be for our amazing donors who've donated
towards this project. This is
unbelievable. It's like telling her
husband, are you not going to tell me
you love me? Are you going to tell me
you love me or not? Like it's like it's
like a life and death matter situation
for her. Yeah. Are you going Are you
going to
>> Hang on. Hang on one second. Just one
David Lami and the British government.
You made that point. Hang on. This is
our in this genocide.
>> I mean well done. She did fantastic.
That's kind of Let's see. Let's see what
this man has to say.
>> You cannot sit there and seriously say
you will not condemn Hamas who have
brought Hang on. Well, you can. I tell
you what, the British public are
watching you.
>> Exactly. She has every right under the
freedom of speech act to say whatever
she likes. Nobody can say to me or
anyone for that matter, I don't need to
condemn nothing, my friend. Okay? The
only thing I condemn is anyone that
don't like hummus for that matter. Okay?
Other than that, nobody can come and
tell me to condemn nothing. Okay? For
whatever reason, it says, "I don't want
to condemn. Who are you to come and tell
me I have to condemn and I have to?" No,
I don't have to. She has every right to
say she's not. Yes, they are more
concerned about what Bob Villain said
rather than the atrocities. He's talking
about IDF soldiers. If I came and said
death, death to ISIS instead of death,
death to the IDF. If I said death to
ISIS, nobody can almost come and say
that's isophobic. It's not phobic at
all. If I said death to the Russian
army, nobody will say anything at all.
Why is it when it's death to the IDF
when they are committing atrocities and
no one has ever claimed to say death to
the Jews? That would be completely
wrong, 100% anti-semitic. Death to all
Israelis. Again, that's wrong. Can't put
all Israelis on the category. But
they're talking about a foreign army
that's committing a genocide. If he says
that, that's freedom of speech. He's
talking about an army, a foreign army
for that matter. So I'm trying to
understand if I say death to ISIS which
all day every day I would because they
will commit atrocities. How does that
make one understandable?
>> The British public are watching you and
if you will not condemn terrorists,
people who have caused absolute chaos
upon the Palestinian people, the ones
that started this conflict. Sorry,
started this conflict. Let's just let's
just get our facts straight. Okay, let's
let's just make it clear, guys. Okay,
I'm not a pro Hamas or pro this or that.
I'm just trying to understand what you
mean they started it. They did not start
it. and should write the P saying minus
please.
>> Can you see the disdain the British
public the people of Palestine is Jewish
people will have for you?
>> I'm happy to condemn terrorists. Let's
start with her.
>> Let's start with Karma. Let's start with
David. No, start with the people that
started this war. Who started this war?
Then condemn Israel.
>> They started this war. They stole those
lands. Start with Israel then. You fool.
You flipping intellectual You
Yes. Why don't you start with it?
Why don't you start with them? Cuz
they're the ones who started all this.
talk about who started the war on
October.
>> I'll tell you it began in 1948 with the
forced No, it did not. Some people would
actually No, no, no, it did not. Yes.
And what are you speaking from? Facts.
Uh fiction. What are you speaking of?
No, no, no. Where's your evidence? You
fool.
>> The back we can get into a correct you
are. You are so correct. In fact, the
British the British were entirely
involved in setting up the Zionist
state. They were entirely involved in
that. So, British imperialism
historically is responsible for those
crimes and today it is still responsible
for those crimes. And what makes you so
angry actually is the fact that more
people support people like Bob Villain.
More people in Britain actually want to
see an end to the occupation. They don't
support Britain sending arms want
you.
>> I mean I applaud this young lady. What a
strongminded
woman that she went there. She did not
fall for any of their bull crap and
rightly so. She has no offer. She does
she does not have to condemn anyone for
that matter. Okay. She if she she
chooses not to. It doesn't mean if one
doesn't condemn a Smith organization
that they support them. No. Yes. Okay.
So the matter is very clear and the ones
that are committing genocide for this
it's very clear is IDF. They are the
ones and it is ironic and subhan Allah.
This is why in Islam it's we are told
that we should be upholders of justice
and speak the truth even if it's against
our own self. No Muslim should ever
defend another Muslim if they are
committing atrocities. And that's the
reason why when it comes to when ISIS
was committing atrocities, every Muslim
from your lay man like myself, your
Muslim who works at 9 to5 to public
figures, YouTubers, imams, scholars,
shes all around the world were
condemning them. But you see the odd
thing with the opposite with Israel. go
to gold is green and ask and I'm not
saying all of them go and ask them there
was a study done and I said 90 or 90% of
the British Israelis they support Israel
they actually support what's going on
these people on all different levels
sadly Zionists not Jews Zionists make
that distinction because we've got many
Jewish friends who support the Palestine
cause so I want to applaud this young
lady for having a backbone and that
other woman there who as you can see is
a big sellout who is there trying to
ignore the atrocities, the crime, the
massacre, the genocide that's happened
and she's more concerned about do you
condemn Hamas? We condemn anyone that
doesn't pray namas.